all right well democrats use covid to
implement their socialist wish list
many red state governors lifted all
restrictions months ago
and the results have been incredibly
positive eight weeks after governor
abbott in texas lifted all statewide
mandates
the coveted numbers remain incredibly
low and florida
just saw its lowest positive rate since
march
now governor ron desantis has a message
for those receiving unemployment in his
state start
looking for a job joining us now with
reaction
is former trump white house chief of
staff reince priebus
and texas attorney general ken paxton
who is a board member to the newly
announced
election integrity alliance uh gentlemen
thank you so much for
for joining us uh mr attorney general i
want to start with you because
texas has helped lead the way in many of
these facets
including getting rid of the
restrictions from your point of view how
is it going and
why should other states do what texas is
doing
well other states should do or do we're
doing because it works both from a job
standpoint an
economic standpoint people of our state
are benefiting people are moving to our
state
by the droves from these states that are
not open and then from a health
standpoint we're doing just as well
you've seen the numbers you've cited the
numbers
uh we're doing really well and as
vaccinations have gone up
and we have more hurt we have more
immunity it's it's just going very well
in texas and i think you can see it just
by
those people coming to our state for
jobs and for opportunity
now right you look at montana governor
gianforte you look at
governor mcmaster there in south
carolina
they're also telling people get up off
the couch and get back to work
how do you think that's going to be
received by the general residents within
those states and across the country
well thanks jason well i think first of
all like your last panel said
this is one of the very few
opportunities
that is so easy to show what happens
when government
interferes in the free market economy
when
you have the president united states
saying
we the people are the government
it's no surprise that you have 7.4
million
jobs that are available and only three
less than 300
000 people found work and that's because
our democrats thought it would be really
generous
to provide people more money to remain
unemployed
than to go find a job now think about
what we're saying in order for these
businesses to be successful
they have to be able to talk people out
of
receiving free money and instead
going to work and on top of it all
schools are closed
which is something that wasn't mentioned
yet when you add
all of that up together you have
exactly what thomas jefferson said when
he said
government big enough to supply
everything you need
is big enough to take everything you
have
and that's really where we're heading
in this country and it's pretty
frightening
and today was a classic example for
everyone to see
what so many people like ronald reagan
and others have warned us about when
government gets too big
yeah the foreshadowing of that was
absolutely truly remarkable mr attorney
general it does scare me this approach
towards socialism
now i've got a technical question
because it really does bother me that
the catch and release program that the
biden harris
administration has put into place is
allowing by the hundreds of thousands of
people to come in this country
who haven't adjudicated through their
asylum claims
or they may or be here illegally and
they just got released into the homeland
but what are they supposed to do for
jobs and income and food and shelter
they're now competing with legal lawful
americans aren't they
absolutely and this is what happened
during the trump administration he was
able to slow that
down by bill starting to build the wall
by letting border patrol and customs and
immigration do their job
in my and having the stay in mexico
program and so what the result of that
was was higher wages
for almost everyone and now with cheap
labor coming in illegals coming in
that will definitely have an impact on
people's ability to have higher wages
and have jobs so it's it's it's shocking
and
unfortunate that president biden hasn't
followed the policies that have worked
for my state and for
most states across this country
well i'm sure that's that's exactly why
you know vice president harris just
just got down to the border just as
quick as she could
go talk to texas and find out what was
happening look i've only got about 20
seconds left right but
this uh culture of dependence this
dependence that the biden harris
administration is putting
upon america how do you think that's
going to play out in the election in
2022
well i mean if we continue down this
road
what you said before in your last panel
is the other piece of this which is
the trillions of dollars that biden
spent on the covet relief package which
has created now this mess
is only going to be followed up with
another
trillions of dollars and the selling
point is going to be we need to spend
trillions more to create more jobs that
the last trillions of dollars that we
spent
didn't create i mean this is spiraling
out of control
um and hopefully you know no one wants
this to continue hopefully maybe things
will even out but
businesses are hurting and you know what
obviously it is going to hit everyone
eventually
and it's going to be a bad deal
yes gentlemen thank you so much for
joining us tonight hey sean hannity here
hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else